that is with us in Minnesota hi Matt how
are you
ID how are you doing today better than I
deserve what's up
I'm just want to say that I'm very
blessed to talk to you and for all you
do for everybody well thank you how can
I help
yeah so I have a question me and my wife
I'm trying not to get emotional here
we've been going through a rough patch
for the last year and a half or excuse
me half a year to a year regarding
finances and it just seems like we can't
ever really agree or come to or meet in
the middle I should say just looking at
hopefully getting some hope from you
today what is it you're having trouble
agreeing about just like with everything
just with budget what we want to do two
things like they're just looking at
pretty much this agreeing like where
money's going I'm more of a budget or
she's not she's a free spirit and I'm
the nerd and I'm just trying to like I
said just get some hope because I'm how
long have y'all been married i we just
celebrated our fourth wedding
anniversary on November 28th so how old
are you in your late 20s
um I'm 30 I just turned 33 the other day
and she is 31 okay all right so do you
have other areas of your marriage that
you just don't agree on things um no
this pretty much this mostly the
financial aspect of it like heard mom
passed away at 40 from breast cancer and
like my mom and dad never really taught
me really about money my mom and dad use
credit cards and my wife's mom was a
single mom her dad's an alcoholic so I
think it's just our our normal way of
living are hers I should say I am trying
to change that mm-hmm so
when you guys sit down and talk about
this you say the best way to live our
dreams and accomplish our goals is for
us to be an agreement on the spending if
the spending not to exceed our income
she's unwilling to do that yeah he just
feels at it to grasp if she feels like
she's being controlled I just feel like
I loved my wife with all my heart but I
don't want I think she is being
controlled I think you're a super nerd
and her vote doesn't count mm-hmm like
like I said like I've I've even told her
does that sound okay to you and she says
yeah and then and then a couple days
later she just changes her mind
yeah yeah she wasn't really agreeing
she's just trying to get rid of you
mm-hmm so you didn't really have
agreement from her so there's a couple
things going on it sounds like from the
outside looking in for one minute so I
don't know how good my insight is but my
guess is after having done this for a
long time that you're a little bit like
me and that you're a super nerd except
you're also a tightwad so you don't like
there's even money on anything and you'd
like to tighten everything down and
really super tight and she sees the
budget as a way that you are using this
to control her instead of somehow having
a conversation where the two of you
understand that her vote is equal to
yours her vote is equal to yours and not
just like oh yeah whatever you want to
do honey which means I'm gonna blow this
thing up that's what that means
she's not gonna wear anything you said
that she said she was gonna she didn't
really mean it yeah you just do whatever
you want to do that crazy but stuff you
can work on that's what she's saying and
just waving you off so instead you've
got to get some emotional involvement to
where the two of you can get on the same
page because when you as you have found
when you cannot agree on your spending
you've not really agreed on your life
when you earn your spending Jesus said
your treasure is where your heart is and
when you put your treasure together
the together we decide how we are gonna
live our life it creates a unity and a
oneness and a level of communication in
your marriage but in order for that to
occur she's got to believe her vote
counts that her voice counts and you
have been the loudest voice in the room
on this subject you're not a loud person
volume wise but you're taking up all the
air on this subject and so probably you
go back and start with okay what would
you like to do if we were wealthy and
shut up and listen mm-hmm and just get
her dreaming about what it would be like
to have a couple of million dollars okay
now I think I can I think if we work
together we can have a good life while
we pursue that great life and there's
some things we've got to do to get that
going and we've you know but we've got
to be on the same page because no one
wants to be controlled no one wants to
be in a situation where their vote
doesn't count no one unless they've got
psychological issues no one wants to
live on beans and rice for no reason
just because it's fun no one wants to
live on a scorched earth and never spend
money ever for anything even a saver
enjoy spending money on some things
that's their purpose of saving so I
think that you are such a detailed
person that you've got the screws
tightened down so tight that she does
not feel the room to actually have a
vote and and it sounds like if you can't
get through this in the next week or two
start talking about what it'd be like to
have two million dollars okay well how
do you think we can get there well you
can't get there well I think we can I
think we got to work together and let's
talk about how we can work together and
let's put this down on paper but you
have to really come to the table honey
you got to really sit down with me and
you're gonna really talk about this and
you got to really put your your wisdom
and insight into this too it's not just
me carrying you along I didn't really
sign up to be your daddy I signed up to
be your husband
means we work together I don't need a
kid there has to be taken care of and if
you can't get past that you probably
need to see a marriage counselor and you
probably need to see a marriage
counselor anyway I'm not sure you guys
have got the relational skillset to work
through this it doesn't sound like it
sounds like you've given it a really
good run but try a couple more of those
things but that's how she's feeling it
sounds to me like it sounds like she's
feels controlled and like her vote does
not count and so she just waves you off
and says well whatever you want to do
walks away and goes and does whatever
the flip she wants today
that's not agreement on a budget and so
if you can get agreement on the budget
the only way you're going to get that is
there's agreement on the reason we're
doing a budget is because it's gonna
take us somewhere towards wealth so we
can be more generous so we can travel so
we can have a nicer car so we can be
more generous whatever it is you're
gonna do right I mean whatever it is it
turns you on that when you get some
money someday you're gonna do that
that's what you're looking for so hey
thanks for the call